tenemos la ecuación menos 9 menos toda
esta expresión 9 x menos 6 - 9 9 x 6 que
es igual a 3 que multiplica a toda esta
otra expresión 4x + 6 lo primero que
vamos a hacer para resolver esta
ecuación es quitar los paréntesis
realizar las multiplicaciones indicadas
aquí en aunque no aparece es como si
tuviéramos un 1 es decir está menos 1
multiplicando 9 x menos seis vamos a
ponerlo de hecho y del lado derecho 3
está multiplicando a 4 x + 6
aplicando entonces la propiedad
distributiva que tenemos del lado
izquierdo menos nueve menos uno que
multiplica a 9 x menos seis menos uno
por 9 x nos da menos 9 x y menos 1 por
menos 6 nos da más 66 positivo del lado
derecho vamos a distribuir el 3
por 4x es igual a 12 x mientras que 3
por 6 es igual a 18 más 18 bien aquí
tenemos dos términos constantes que
podemos combinar el menos 9 y el 6
aquí tenemos 12 x + 18 que no podemos
combinar no son términos semejantes pero
del lado izquierdo si son términos
semejantes podemos combinar este menos 9
con este más 6 de tal manera que del
lado izquierdo nos queda entonces menos
9 x menos 9 x más veamos sumamos menos
96 esto nos da menos 3 entonces sería
menos 9 x menos 3 menos 96 es menos 3
menos 9 x menos 3 y del lado derecho se
queda igual 12 x más 18
ahora vamos a agrupar los términos en x
de un lado y los términos constantes del
otro lado a mí me gusta agrupar los
términos en x del lado izquierdo no es
siempre si así pero vamos a hacerlo en
este caso vamos a agrupar los términos
en x del lado izquierdo así es que para
eliminar este 12 x del lado derecho voy
a restar 12 x a ambos lados de la
ecuación restando 12 x del lado derecho
y como bien sabes también tenemos que
restar 2x del lado izquierdo que nos
resulta ahora del lado izquierdo menos 9
x menos 12 x es igual a menos 21 x menos
21 x menos 3 y eso es igual a 12 x menos
12 x es igual a 0 se cancelan podría
poner el 0 aquí pero no es necesario que
lo haga por eso restamos 2x para
cancelar ese 12 x de arriba así es que
del lado derecho nos queda tan solo este
18 es igual a 18 sólo nos queda el 18
pues esto se canceló
ahora eliminemos este menos 3 del lado
izquierdo para que nos queden de lado
izquierdo sólo términos en x y del lado
derecho nos queden solo términos
constantes la mejor manera de cancelar
menos 13 sumarle 3 para que llegue a 0
así es que sumamos 3 del lado izquierdo
y sumamos 3 del lado derecho y ahora que
tenemos del lado izquierdo solo menos 21
x no hay más términos en x para combinar
este menos 3 con este más 3 se cancelan
ese fue el objeto de sumar 3 a la
ecuación lo cual es igual a 18 más 3 18
321 hemos llegado a la ecuación menos 21
x igual a 21 queremos despejar la x para
despejar la x que está multiplicada por
algo hay que dividirla entre s algo por
lo que para despejar la x tenemos que
dividir menos 21 x entre menos 21 y
también tenemos que dividir el lado
derecho entre menos 21 obtenemos
entonces del lado izquierdo menos 21
entre menos 21 se cancelan y nos queda
tan solo x y esto es igual a 21 entre
menos 21 no está simplemente menos 1
algo positivo dividido entre sí mismo
negativo nos da siempre menos 1 así que
ahí tenemos nuestra respuesta aquí
tenemos las
comprobemos la solución para esto
sustituimos el valor de x igual a menos
uno en la ecuación original tenemos
entonces menos 9 lo voy a hacer por acá
de hecho voy a usar un color distinto a
los que hemos estado usando tenemos
menos nueve menos este menos uno no
estaba en la ecuación original está de
manera implícita 9 que multiplica a
menos 1 lo voy a poner entre paréntesis
menos uno menos seis y esto que es igual
déjame hacer del lado izquierdo voy a
resolver primero de izquierda y lo vamos
a comprar con el lado derecho entonces
aquí tenemos menos 9 menos 9 x menos 1
es menos 9 menos 6 vamos a quitar el
paréntesis menos 9 menos 9 menos seis
son menos 15 aquí tenemos menos 15 aquí
tenemos menos 9 déjame checar si se
viene esto 9 y 6 son 15 al ser negativos
menos 15 sí sí está bien tenemos menos 9
menos menos 15 este lo mismo que menos 9
15 15 9 es igual a 6 así es que al
sustituir x igual a menos 1 en el lado
izquierdo de la ecuación original
obtenemos 6 veamos que obtenemos cuando
sustituimos x igual a menos 1 en el lado
derecho de la ecuación lo voy a hacer en
verde tenemos 3 que multiplica a 4 x
menos 1 + 6 y esto nos da 3 que
multiplica a menos 46 menos 46 es 2
esto es 3 por 2 que también es igual a 6
así es que cuando sustituimos x igual a
menos 1 en el lado izquierdo obtuvimos 6
y también cuando lo sustituimos en el
lado derecho obtuvimos 6 así es que está
definitivamente es la solución